[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec à la une
cette semaine un mot et une réalité
nommée la sobriété à Amiens université
vient d'annoncer qu'il y a de la
limitera son chauffage à 19 degrés cet
hiver réaction des étudiants notamment à
suivre dans quelques instants avec WeHo
télé la chaîne de la Voix du Nord une
profession envoie de disparition les
vétérinaires ruraux sont de moins en
moins nombreux à couvrir les besoins des
animaux d'élevage en France reportage
dans les pas d'un professionnel dans
cette édition avec télé Grenoble
une oeuvre impressionnante également à
découvrir celle d'un artiste plasticien
qui a reconstitué l'ancien Théâtre de la
Ville du Mans à l'aide d'une tonne de
papier carton et une performance
monumentale et participative nous
expliquera la rédaction de LM TV Sarthe
et puis en fin de journal des images
aériennes et impressionnantes de nos
confrères de la Dépêche du Midi qui ont
pu embarquer avec 600 parachutistes lors
d'un exercice militaire des images à
bord incroyables vous le verrez
l'été officiellement terminé l'heure de
la sobriété sonne déjà pour les Français
collectivités entreprises particuliers
petits ou grands tout le monde est
invité à réduire sa consommation
d'énergie à Amiens vous allez le voir
l'université prendra pas à l'effort en
baissant la température du chauffage
dans ces bâtiments à 19 degrés objectif
faire des économies alors que les prix
du gaz et de l'électricité ont fortement
augmenté les étudiants salut
l'initiative écologique et se prépare en
se couvrant comme a pu le constater
Jérémy houblon pour oui au TV la chaîne
de la Voix du Nord
le mercure descend et les écharpes sont
de sortie devant l'université Picardie
Jules Verne le thermomètre occupe les
conversations et pour cause l'UPGV
prévoit de baisser le chauffage c'est
pas dérangeant si c'est pas trop baissé
parce que faut pas non plus qu'on soit
dans des situations de précarité etc
comment on fait des économies d'énergie
et en même temps je trouve ça embêtant
parce que on va voir froid donc il va
falloir bien s'habiller quand même
sobriété énergétique oblige l'université
envisage de baisser le thermostat
passant de 20 à 19 degrés dans
l'ensemble de ces bâtiments on
s'aperçoit que on a encore à 20,5 degrés
pour une température extérieure de 13
degrés et donc effectivement la
température sera maintenue à 19 degrés
donc un petit peu moins que ce qu'il en
est actuellement amphithéâtre salle de
cours bureau administratifs quelques 300
000 m² de bâtiment partagés sur six
campus verront le chauffage BC une
mesure pour faire face au surco
énergétique sur les dernières années on
a à peu près à 3000 5 de factures
d'énergie là on estime qu'on va
augmenter de 3 millions d'euros et qu'on
sera plutôt plutôt à la fin 2022 à 6
millions 5 c'est une des réponses il y
en a d'autres il y a la période de
chauffe et puis il y a tout
l'investissement que l'on peut faire
pour rénover nos bâtiments d'un point de
vue thermique à ce jour pas question de
revenir au cours à distance de quoi
rassurer les syndicats étudiants
pourtant quelques questions subsistent
notamment celle de l'accompagnement
financier promis par la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur c'est une
initiative on salue en fait parce que
elle est elle est pas très coûteuse sur
le plan de scolaire ou sur le plan
universitaire maintenant on est voilà on
sait jamais ce qui peut arriver par la
suite on sait pas c'est une inflation va
augmenter encore on sait pas si on aura
su les financements de du ministère la
mesure devrait s'appliquer après les
vacances de la Toussaint l'UPJV espère
ainsi s'approcher un peu plus de
l'objectif majeur baisser la
consommation d'énergie de 10% à
l'horizon 2024
voilà ici baisser sa consommation
d'électricité ou de gaz c'est bon pour
le porte-monnaie c'est aussi bon vous
l'aurez compris pour l'environnement
parce que les énergies fossiles aux
énergies renouvelables c'est d'ailleurs
l'autre grand défi du gouvernement et
au-delà des projets privés certaines
initiatives citoyennes voient le jour un
peu partout en France exemple en
Bretagne ou des habitants se sont réunis
pour créer le premier parc éolien
participatif loin des polémiques un
million d'euros a été investi reportage
de Mathilde quéménère de Tébéo la chaîne
du groupe télégramme en Bretagne
en centre Bretagne sur les communes
d'illifo et de Merdrignac 311 citoyens
ont investi au total un million d'euros
pour construire quatre éoliennes ici il
n'y a pas eu de contestation et c'est
une première en France ils sont aussi
décisionnaires ils sont actionnaires ils
vont pouvoir je dirais vous voir comment
fonctionne et quels sont les ils vont
évidemment avoir des questions des
suggestions des critiques comme tout
l'actionnaire j'ai mis 10000 euros les
énergies fossiles gaz charbon pétrole ce
sont des ressources qui ne sont pas
inépuisables il est grand temps de
penser aux générations futures et aussi
un intérêt financier puisque bon le
financement participatif est rémunéré
sur la base de entre 6 et 7%, ce qui est
aujourd'hui relativement économiquement
intéressant et c'est aussi intéressant
pour les communes une somme leur est
redistribué la société va financer la
remise en état de certaines routes ainsi
qu'un aménagement dans le bourg
d'illiffaut parce que nous collectivités
le qu'on a au jour d'aujourd'hui on a
plus de taxes d'habitation faut qu'on
équilibre nos budgets 7000 euros par
éolienne ça fait 15000 euros et 15000
euros ça nous permet de rembourser un
prêt de 200000 euros sur 15 ans c'est
qu'on est un peu plus de retombées parce
que bon qui c'est comme profil c'est
quand même la ville c'est 4 éoliennes
vont produire l'équivalent de la
consommation électrique de 14000
habitants face au succès deux autres
projets sont déjà prévus sur ce
territoire avec sûrement là aussi
d'autres financements participatifs
voilà ici le manque d'eau était un coup
d'arrêt à l'urbanisation de nos
territoires la question peut prêter ta
sourire mais elle se pose sérieusement
dans les rôles depuis que plusieurs
mairies ont dû refuser des permis de
construire faute d'un volume suffisant
d'eau une situation qui pourrait durer
des années le temps que des travaux de
raccordement nécessaires soient réalisés
les explications de Mélanie Caron pour
via Occitanie regardez
à Montarnaud de nouveau logement
fleurissent en continu mais ce
développement devrait s'arrêter
brutalement en septembre la commune a
atteint son quota do annuel la mairie a
donc été mise en garde par ses
fournisseurs si les constructions se
poursuivent certains ne pourront pas se
raccorder au réseau d'eau je vois pas
comment je peux délivrer un permis parce
que je délivre un permis qui ne
permettrait pas aux personnes curéatives
de pouvoir se raccorder à l'eau donc
deux solutions soit une solution
d'économie d'eau par une gestion que
font tous les citoyens soit une solution
de arrêt momentané de du développement
de la commune en bloquant les permis de
construire l'eau du territoire est géré
à quelques kilomètres de là au Grand Pic
Saint-Loup le problème ne provient pas
d'un manque de ressources mais des
infrastructures pour la cheminée trop
ancienne elles ne sont plus adaptées aux
besoins croissants des communes on va
mettre en production un nouveau forage
qui est à situation
du Red
qui une fois qui sera en service
brusquement nous redonner un volume
extrêmement important qui nous évitera
toutes les difficultés qu'on connaît
actuellement un nouveau forage qui ne
sera peut-être pas en service avant 2026
en attendant la commune de Montarnaud
prévoit de suspendre tous les permis de
construire
voilà et des manques ou plutôt des
problèmes de recrutement ils sont
nombreux dans plusieurs secteurs de
l'économie en nouvelle-aquitaine près
d'un millier de postes d'ambulanciers
sont encore à pourvoir faute de
candidats sur toute la France ce chiffre
s'élève à 15000 alors pour remédier à
cette pénurie de manœuvre les
professionnels réclament plusieurs
mesures dont un accès facilité à la
formation explication divan branchies
journalistes de TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest
une femme enceinte vient de composer le
15 en quelques minutes l'ambulance
arrive sur le lieu pour prendre en
charge la patiente
une mission quotidienne pour ces deux
ambulanciers qui doivent prodiguer les
premiers soins si besoin et assurer le
transport un métier passion mais qui
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté en
France vous avez 5000 sociétés
d'ambulance
55000 salariés et nous avons 15000
postes à pourvoir c'est beaucoup
si on fait un focus sur la nouvelle
Aquitaine c'est plus de 1000 postes à
pourvoir et rien qu'en Gironde vous avez
environ 150 postes à pourvoir crise
sanitaire méconnaissance du métier cette
profession féminisée à 40% connaît une
pénurie malgré un salaire entre 1600 et
2100 euros brut selon le volume d'or de
travail le secteur se mobilise donc pour
recruter en mettant sur la table
plusieurs propositions la première chose
c'est d'avoir une formation qui soit
accessible dès les 18 ans actuellement
il faut trois ans de permis la deuxième
chose
c'est une validation des acquis
d'expérience qu'ils ont acquis en
entreprise le troisième point c'est un
bac pro ambulancier
ça permettrait de mieux connaître ce
métier qui est attractif qui permettrait
aux jeunes de se s'orienter sur ce
métier de la santé selon la Chambre
nationale des services d'ambulance il y
a urgence car si rien n'est fait les
personnes fragiles et isolées pourraient
être les premières touchées par ce
manque de main d'oeuvre
sentez toujours avec un focus à présent
sur une autre profession en mal de
vocation celle des vétérinaires ruraux
un métier méconnu et délaissé vous allez
le voir en Isère ils ne sont plus qu'une
dizaine à exercer le métier deux fois
moins qu'il y a 10 ans parmi ces
infatigables Benjamin Dubaï il exerce
une activité qui alterne à la fois
animaux de compagnie et animaux de la
ferme un reportage de Laurie Bayet pour
la chaîne télé Grenoble
en Isère comme par tout en France il y a
de moins en moins de vétérinaires ruraux
ils ne sont plus qu'une quinzaine à
travailler dans le département soit 10
vétérinaires de moins qu'il y a 10 ans
Benjamin Dubail s'est installé ici à
Chabons en 2019 il exerce une activité
mixte entre vaches chevaux cochons et
animaux de compagnie notre activité en
rurale doit être à peu près à 30% je
préfère à peu près 30% de vaches ici le
reste étant les animaux de compagnie
pour avoir un vétérinaire rural il faut
avoir des clients des clients ce sont
les vaches si les vaches diminuent le
nombre de vétérinaires diminue et pour
garantir un service aux éleveurs le
département de l'Isère lance Isère veto
un dispositif qui veut favoriser
l'installation de nouveaux vétérinaires
en milieu rural l'objectif garantir une
surveillance sanitaire du territoire en
maintenant un maillage suffisant quand
vous avez une zone géographique avec
beaucoup de vaches au mètre carré c'est
beaucoup plus facile de travailler que
lorsque les vaches sont espacées moi ici
étant seul et bien si j'ai un client qui
m'appelle d'un côté de la clientèle et
un autre après qui a une urgence de
l'autre côté je dois faire 50 km pour
relier les deux points sur le modèle
diverses actions prévoit une aide de
forfaitaire à l'installation de 15
000 une indemnité kilométrique et une
indemnité de logement de 300 euros par
mois pour les étudiants il faut
absolument avoir des jeunes vétérinaires
qui se mettent en place parce que grâce
à ça sur du long terme on peut espérer
encore avoir quelqu'un ils servaient
tout profite d'une première enveloppe de
80000 euros pour l'année 2022 puis d'un
budget annuel d'environ 100000 euros
certains sont toxiques d'autres
comestibles vous êtes nombreux ces
jours-ci à vous balader en forêt à la
recherche de champignons mais savez-vous
les différencier difficile parfois tant
ils sont nombreux et alors pour éviter
tout danger le plus simple est encore de
demander la vie d'un pharmacien dans les
Vosges les étudiants en pharmacie sont
formés lors de sortie en forêt reportage
de Thierry lassion et d'Hélène le plat
pour vos jeux TV
du soleil puis de la pluie en cette fin
d'été il n'en fallait pas davantage pour
que la cueillette soit bonne mais vous
dire qu'à l'issue de ce reportage vous
deviendrez un spécialiste des
champignons serait bien prétentieux
tellement il y a d'espèces à plus de
10000 en Europe quant au Grand Est c'est
à peu près 400 000 espèces comment
reconnaître les toxiques des comestibles
il faut les apprendre c'est la seule
solution différencier des champignons
comestibles de ceux qui ne le sont pas
c'est la raison de leur venue sur le
terrain une vingtaine d'étudiants de la
Faculté de Pharmacie de Nancy encadrée
par des membres de la Société Lorraine
de mycologie c'est la seule faculté qui
propose des enseignements pratiques de
mycologie en deuxième troisième
quatrième cinquième et 6e année les
champignons sont toxiques à l’ingestion
par exemple si on trouve aujourd'hui une
phalloïde moi je l'accueille et après je
mange mon sandwich il y a aucun souci
les champignons sont toxiques à
l'ingestion donc il faut pas les manger
et goûter un toxic oui mais c'est comme
le vin on recrache et il y a pas il y a
pas de souci quand on est en TP on voit
juste les champignons mais on les voit
pas vraiment dans leur état naturel là
c'est plus sympa c'est nous qui les
trouvons c'est nous qui les identifions
donc c'est c'est quand même plus
pratique puis on retient mieux je pense
aussi enroulé donc ça c'est quelque
chose de mortelle en fait ça fait partie
des sept mortels qu'on a ici et qu'il
faut absolument connaître en fait que
soit en tant que formation même en tant
que cueilleur de champignons simple
c'est important surtout pour les
pharmaciens qui sont
officines de campagne parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de patients qui vont à la
chasse aux champignons mais qui savent
pas forcément ou alors qu'ils peuvent se
tromper donc c'est important pour les
pharmaciens de campagne après en ville
c'est beaucoup plus rare mais je pense
que quand même dans le cursus ça sert
toujours ces étudiants devront suivre 5
séances de ce type sur le terrain avant
un examen poussé pour identifier les
différentes espèces et peut-être même
les goûter mise à part certaines
facilement reconnaissables
prenons la direction de la Martinique à
présent dans ce journal ou comme partout
ailleurs les cours ont repris depuis un
mois désormais et sur l'île aussi des
familles ont fait le choix de l'école à
la maison en plus des traditionnelles
leçons de mathématiques de français ou
géographie donnée par les parents les
enfants ont aussi le droit à des sorties
ludiques au milieu de la faune et de la
flore martiniquaise reportage d'autres
Seoul tidas pour via TV Martinique sur
place
tous les matins à 9h Théo étudie avec sa
maman Catherine cela fait 4 ans que
cette famille a décidé de faire l'école
à la maison pour aider Théo en
difficulté scolaire dans ces pays il
avait énormément de difficultés pour
apprendre à lire et à écrire c'était pas
du tout fluide c'était pas du tout
simple et c'était très compliqué on a
décidé de l'enlever pour lui faire une
pause en fait pour qu'il puisse souffler
se retrouver et en s'y rendu compte
qu'en fin au final il a appris en plus
de son activité professionnelle cette
maman consacre sa matinée à l'éducation
de son petit garçon de 10 ans et ses
soirées à la recherche de cours et
d'exercices pour le lendemain les
manuels scolaires et activités ludique
sont dans tous les placards de la maison
en regardant généralement on a fini le
programme de l'année
ça va vite y a qu'un enfant donc une
fois que c'est fait la leçon elle est si
en classe il faut peut-être une heure
pour faire une leçon ici la leçon elle
peut être faite en un quart d'heure donc
ça va quand même très vite les activités
ludiques prennent une grande place dans
l'apprentissage direction Lille et
chancelle un animateur du réseau de
protection de l'iguane des Petites
Antilles elle enseignant aujourd'hui
l'instruction en famille ce mercredi et
comme tous les autres jours on apprend
des choses tout en s'amusant les parents
ont décidé d'inclure un maximum de
sorties éducatives pour enrichir la
culture des enfants surtout mes deux
derniers qui ont un peu plus de mal avec
l'écrit avec le visuel
vivre l'expérience va leur permettre
d'intégrer un peu plus les connaissances
et en tout cas les retenir tous les ans
les parents souhaitant pratiquer
l'instruction en famille sont inspectés
par l'Académie les enfants subissent des
tests afin de savoir s'ils ont le niveau
requis pour leur âge
c'est l'un des repas préférés des
Français plébiscités le dimanche soir ou
lors d'une pause déjeuner l'appétit pour
les pizzas n'est plus approuvé dans
notre pays et si manger une bonne pizza
est évidemment un plaisir la faire
soi-même c'est encore mieux dans le
Val-d'Oise un pizzaïolo confirmé triple
champion du monde propose des ateliers
pour les particuliers objectifs leur
transmettre ces astuces et recettes pour
des pizzas réussi à domicile embarquez
pour un tour en Italie depuis la région
parisienne avec ce sujet de Michael Joly
de la rédaction devient 95
tout ce que je fais vous allez voir que
vous allez pouvoir le faire aussi
réussir à faire comme lui c'est la
promesse faite par Thierry graffaninho
triple champion du monde de la pizza
assez novice ils vont pendant 4 heures
découvrir les astuces du champion et les
mettre en pratique au programme mélange
des ingrédients pétrissage des pâtons et
le clou du spectacle vers tournoyer la
patte plus vous allez donner de
l'impulsion plus ça va tourner et ça ça
permet d'avoir un étalage uniforme à
l'origine d'un institut mondial de la
pizza et habituellement formateur pour
des pizzaiolo avertis le triple champion
du monde val-d'oisien propose depuis
début 2022 ces stages au grand public
les Français adorent les pizzas et
aujourd'hui depuis ce Satani covid tout
le monde a commencé à cuisiner dans les
jardins ou ailleurs et beaucoup de gens
se sont mis à la pizza mais
malheureusement sur les réseaux sociaux
on trouve beaucoup de choses qui les
induisent en erreur donc ils viennent
ici un petit peu pour corriger le tir et
puis pas faire de bonnes pizzas à la
maison c'est comme ça
mais excellent et après 4 heures de
stage les conseils sont bien intégrés
par les novices
qui s'estime très pour pratiquer un
nouveau chez eux on progresse assez vite
dans l'atelier tu prends un coup de main
et après aussi pourquoi faire tourner la
pâte à pizza on prend assez vite le coup
de main bon on l'a pas du premier coup
bien sûr quoi mais aussi c'est pas un
truc trop folklorique ou trop
spectaculaire ça est vraiment une
utilité et ça il nous explique Thierry
et c'est super stop quoi j'avais des
difficultés à créer du coup juste à
faire la pâte à pizza en elle-même et
puis après faire des pizzas mangeables
tout simplement et du coup l'atelier
c'était vraiment une solution super
intéressante et puis très conviviale
pour le coup et ça a débloqué pas mal de
sujets contraignant de mon côté les
ateliers sont ouverts à tous les publics
il nous triple champion du monde
envisage même d'en ouvrir aux enfants
accompagner de leurs parents ou de cette
formation
99 euros
voilà c'est certain désormais réalisé
une belle et bonne pizza est une
prouesse artistique tout comme la
reconstruction en carton d'un ancien
théâtre dans la ville du Mans c'est le
drôle de défi que vient de réaliser
l'artiste Olivier grosses têtes son
œuvre éphémère s'est installé le temps
d'un week-end sur l'emplacement de
l'ancien établissement une réalisation
impressionnante et collégiale comme vous
allez le voir avec ce reportage d'Enzo
Maubert pour LMTv Sarthe
prévoyez une tonne de carton un bon
stock de rouleau de scotch des habitants
bien motivés et vous obtenez une œuvre
monumentale
[Applaudissements]
l'ancien théâtre du Mans ressuscité par
l'artiste Olivier grosses têtes et des
centaines de bénévoles devenus peu à peu
des pros de l'emballage
et même le système D pour couper là
j'aime bien j'aime bien bricoler et puis
j'aime bien rencontrer du monde avec du
monde et participer à une événement
comme ça qui est gratuit qui est
spontané personne se connaît tout le
monde travaille ensemble et ça c'est ça
c'est le côté sympa aussi ouais
vous allez glisser les pièces et vous
laissez les adultes porter chacun vient
comme il veut le temps qu'il veut et
c'est assez beau de voir les gens
travaillent ensemble quoi voilà un
contexte où on met les gens les uns
contre les autres bah là tout d'un coup
autour d'un truc qui sert strictement à
rien sauf à se faire plaisir voilà moi
je trouve que c'est assez beau il aura
fallu une semaine de travail pour
construire ses pièces puis en faire une
cathédrale de cartons de 11 mètres de
haut un beau défi collectif oui pourtant
à la destruction c'est un petit peu
comme un gros lego ou un gros château de
sable ou un mandala quoi plus
spirituellement c'est le fait de faire
et tout ce qui s'y passe à ce moment-là
donc le fait de mettre une fin à ça ça
acte le fait que c'est c'est le chemin
qui est important c'est le processus et
dès le lendemain le théâtre n'était déjà
plus là comme si tout cela n'avait
jamais existé
un projet collectif et solidaire encore
dans ce journal avec cette belle
initiative venue de Corse ou une
association de motards s'est mobilisée
pour réaliser le rêve de Christelle une
personne en situation de handicap qui a
eu la chance de traverser à moto une
partie de l'île de Beauté un défi réussi
et beaucoup de sourire sur le visage de
l'intéressé écoutez là au micro de
Franco farsetti et de Takeo midzuno de
la rédaction de via télé paisé encore
ma mobilité réduite on peut faire
énormément de choses et la moto moi
c'était un plaisir il y a très très
longtemps ça a toujours été un gros gros
plaisir et du coup j'ai dit là
maintenant faut que je le fasse j'ai un
problème de coordination j'ai quand même
de tout donc c'est un vrai défi pour moi
ce que je fais là mais avec des gens
extraordinaires on est encore capable de
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et moi c'est
ce que je veux montrer toute tout au
long de ma vie tout au long de ce qui me
reste à vivre je vais montrer ça je vais
montrer comment faire plein plein de
choses encore
voilà quittons la route pour prendre de
la hauteur cette fin d'édition et
évoquer la 40e édition de l'Icare du
cinéma le Festival International du Film
aérien organisé comme chaque année en
parallèle de la Coupe Icare l'événement
a permis de récompenser de mettre à
l'honneur les professionnels de l'image
et pratiquant de vols libres une
vingtaine de films autour des sports
aériens étaient cette année en
compétition voici les réactions de deux
dés lauréats au micro de Victoria Lopez
pour la rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc
moi je venais là quand j'étais tout
petit mais pendant un instant d'ici puis
je venais voir les films comme ça en
tant que spectateur et je me disais
ouais ces gens ils font rêver c'est
génial un jour j'aimerais vraiment être
quand même et je me disais c'est
vraiment pas possible ça arrivera jamais
et aujourd'hui d'être là et recevoir
deux prix ben ça me touche vraiment
parce que je m'y attendais pas quand on
les faits les projets vidéo est prêt
quand on les fait voir sur un grand
écran il s'appelait aux jambes forcément
c'est c'est la meilleure des récompenses
le rêve dit car justement beaucoup ont
tenté de le réaliser pour voler de leur
propre aile aujourd'hui une pratique se
rapproche du mythe le vol à voile
autrement dit le planeur sans moteur
donc sans bruit cette activité permet
d'imiter les oiseaux à l'aide des
courants atmosphériques à Limoges des
passionnés partagent leur enthousiasme
lors de sortie dans les airs des images
au rythme du souffle du vent avec ce
sujet de Benjamin Delmas pour la
rédaction de cet à Limoges
[Musique]
il est parfois des rêves d'enfants que
l'on vit au quotidien Philippe préside
l'association limousine des sports
aériens m'occupe de sortir les planeurs
c'est avec celui-là que je vais vous
emmener c'est un planeur biplace et on
le pousse en mettant les mains bien à
plat là j'ai toujours rêvé au mois de
voler quand j'étais jeune et j'avais peu
de moyens et donc à l'époque c'était le
moyen le plus accessible pour pour
piloter c'était pour apprendre à piloter
c'était de faire du planeur donc j'ai
appris à faire du planeur j'avais 17 ans
et là j'ai 63 ans et j'en fais j'en fais
encore la levant elle est pas très fort
si je peux monter assez haut on peut
éventuellement aller à Cognac-la-Forêt
l'un des objectifs de l'association
favoriser la pratique du vol à voile et
lever ses appréhensions je dirais même
que c'est même plus sûr que l'avion
parce que nous on s'est se débrouiller
sans moteur on est déjà en panne si on
peut dire ça comme ça et donc c'est non
c'est totalement contrôlé et je trouve
que c'est même c'est même un sport
plutôt sur je dis avant de voler on
s'assure que le planeur il est en état
et cette visiteur on l'a fait tous les
jours ça fonctionne à droite et le rond
se lève une fois les vérifications
d'usage terminé il n'y a plus qu'à
s'installer à bord place au vol
[Musique]
Ant
allez on referme ce journal avec
d'autres images très impressionnantes
celle d'un exercice militaire qui s'est
tenu il y a quelques jours à Castres 600
parachutistes ont été largués depuis un
avion militaire pour le moins imposant
un exercice de défense grandeur nature
auquel a pu assister nos confrères de la
Dépêche du Midi pour nous livrer ces
images rares à bord d'un appareil
militaire propos et explications
recueillies par Clément GACCI écoutez en
fait l'avion est rassemblé dans leur des
câbles dans leur des câbles de saut tous
les parachutistes sont mis dans nos
normes spéciales qui va configurer la
mission au sol pour une mise en place
sur les points initiaux donc les points
de regroupement et en fait chaque câble
est inspecté par un sous-officier qui
est qualifié chef de groupe tap donc qui
vérifie le matériel que le les
parachutistes sont bien équipés
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand JT des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivis
on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]